c'est lors de notre je vous demande de
rester encore trois secondes de notre
second débat autour d'une menace
réapparue évidemment avec le conflit en
Ukraine la menace d'une guerre nucléaire
Vladimir Poutine c'est lieutenant
certains de ses alliés l'agrandissent
régulièrement d'autres pays comme l'Iran
ou la Corée du Nord veulent eux aussi
leur bombe sommes-nous entrer dans le 3e
âge nucléaire avant d'entendre la vie de
nos experts rappelle de la stratégie du
président russe avec Flora sauvage
pas de bluff quand Vladimir Poutine
brandit l'arme nucléaire après la
destruction du pont de Crimée le
président russe a menace et de répliquer
s'il est tentatives d'attentats
terroristes sur notre territoire se
poursuivent les réponses de la Russie
seront sévères et leur ampleur
correspondra au niveau des menaces
posées à la Fédération de Russie
personne ne doit en avoir le moindre
doute si en cas d'attaque Emmanuel
Macron exclut une riposte nucléaire le
chef de la diplomatie européenne a mis
en garde Vladimir Poutine
dit qu'il ne bluff pas et bien il ne
peut pas se permettre de bluffer
toute attaque nucléaire contre l'Ukraine
entraînera une réponse
pas une réponse nucléaire mais une
réponse militaire si puissante que
l'armée russe sera anéantie
utilisait une harmonaire le Secrétaire
général de l'Organisation a affirmé que
même l'util nucléaire de moins
d'envergure changerait fondamentalement
la donne
la rhétorique nucléaire du président
Poutine est dangereuse et irresponsable
oui nous prenons cette menace au sérieux
et nous restons vigilants
nous ne nous resterons pas intimidés
nucléaire de la part de la Russie l'OTAN
mène depuis hier son exercice annuel de
dissuasion nucléaire 14 États membres et
une soixantaine d'avions participent à
cette entraînement qui se déroulera
jusqu'au 30 octobre
[Musique]
au tout début de du conflit en Ukraine à
partir du moment où vous parlez de
dissuasion nucléaire et bien dans
l'intitulé même vous avez la nécessité
déjà de laisser les votre interlocuteur
dans le flou ça fait partie de votre
dissuasion c'est à dire que comme vous
ne savez pas exactement quel est le
niveau qui fait que vous allez risquer
une frappe ni qu'elle sera
potentiellement la nature de la frappe
au cas particulier et bien vous rentrez
dans ce jeu dissuasion pour avoir une
dissuasion il faut qu'il y ait une
crédibilité c'est quelque chose avec
lequel la Russie joue ne serait-ce que
dans son discours diplomatique mais de
longue date rappelons-nous quand les
scanders ont été ont été déployés dans
l'esclave de Kaliningrad par exemple
avec une capacité d'emporte on était
déjà dans une approche de dissuasion
avec quelque part une démonstration
expressive si vous me permettez cette
expression là il y a eu aussi pas de
changements majeurs pour vous là
ce qu'il y a si vous voulez il y a une
il y a une utilisation dans la
rhétorique de mise en avant qui est
extrêmement fréquente même quand on
n'est pas dans des périodes de conflits
comme on l'a ne serait-ce que quand on a
des périodes de tension d'une mise en
avant de la capacité tactique et
stratégique russe militaire russe
rappelons-nous aussi que en mars 2015
dans un documentaire qui était passé à
la télévision le président Poutine avait
expliqué que et bien justement lors de
l'annexion de la Crimée ils avaient mis
en alerte les frappes et qu'ils étaient
prêts à taper donc on a tout ce principe
là ce qu'il y a c'est qu'effectivement
il y a une mise en alerte qui a été très
rapide donc à la fin du mois de du mois
de février alors que l'invasion avait
démarré au 24 et que on est justement
dans cette espèce de principe de
dissuasion que l'on met que l'on met en
avant de manière systémique pour les
raisons qu'on comprend Pascal Boniface
pourquoi alors c'est horrible d'essayer
de se projeter mais pourquoi la lumière
Poutine pourrait-il franchir cette ligne
rouge
il pourrait le franchir il y a deux
types de déclarations chez les Russes il
y a ceux qui sont vraiment en charge du
nucléaire ils disent que la dissuasion
doit protéger des intérêts existentiels
du pays ce qui est d'ailleurs une
doctrine commune à l'ensemble des pays
qui ont nucléaires et puis il y a qu'à
dire Rohff il y a les commentateurs qui
disent il faut frapper il faut se servir
mais eux ils ont pas le doigt sur le
bouton pour prendre une expression qui à
la fois fausse et image donc il faut
bien distinguer ceux qui commentent et
ceux qui agissent et non pas la même
idée alors pourquoi la Russie serait
éventuellement potentiellement en état
ou en contrainte d'utiliser l'arme
nucléaire si elle perd tout si elle
pense que c'est la débandade et pour
renverser la bataille une bataille qui
serait une guerre qui serait perdue mais
même ça je doute qu'il le fasse en cas
de débandade parce que là il perdrait
les derniers contacts qu'ils ont été
pays il y a des pays qui n'ont pas coupé
les ponts avec la Russie en Amérique
latine en Afrique en Asie et si ce tabou
nucléaire était franchi et bien
des pays qui ont encore des relations
avec ta Russie ne pourrait pas en avoir
donc même si quelqu'un dans le pouvoir
russe était tenté pour le faire Poutine
par exemple comme il ne prend pas seul à
décision d'autres je pense te freinerait
en disant là c'est pas seulement le
régime qui est en cause c'est le pays et
on ne peut pas prendre ce risque colonel
perdait donc quand on est dans cette
situation alors il y a l'analyse et puis
il y a comment
la France réagisse et est-ce que on
osse notre niveau de vigilance ou est-ce
que finalement on est dans dans une
continuité en fait la guerre cette
menace j'ai bien compris la guerre en
urée en Ukraine il y a eu trois phases
la première phase qui était extrêmement
déclarative on peut considérer que
Poutine de gesticuler vous savez dans
toute guerre uniforme de gesticulation
tant qu'on est dans la gesticulation ça
paraît acceptable et à l'époque déjà je
vous rappelle on a quatre sous-marins
nucléaire d'engin il avait trois
cavaliers à la mer c'était le maximum du
maximum le quatrième étant en réparation
c'est systématique il y en a toujours un
qui est en maintenance quoi pardon 24
février pour parler
je l'ai je l'ai je l'ai on avait tous et
donc on a mis trois sous-marins à la mer
ce qui en fait énorme je pense que là on
a vraiment on a on a vide les soute
comme on dit après on est revenu un truc
plus raisonnable sachant qu'aujourd'hui
il y a entre 1 et 2 sous-marins qui sont
à la mer donc c'est le maximum qu'on
puisse faire parce que l'autre l'autre
vecteur est un vecteur aérien qui se met
en l'air que si il y a une menace
extrêmement précise le problème
là-dedans c'est la pression de la menace
sur la même chose c'est que entre la
gesticulation il y a eu trois phases en
fait première phase en gesticulé il y
avait une espèce de d'opération j'ai le
kiffer l'opération de communication on
fait Poutine a très clairement cru qu'il
allait rentrer à Kiev quasiment en
quelques jours et on en parlerait plus
la faire c'est réglé on faisait partie
zélinski qui repartait avec sa famille
et ses gosses et puis on mettait
quelqu'un d'autre qui était pro russe et
l'affaire était réglée ça n'a pas
fonctionné pourtant il est utilisé déjà
la menace nucléaire à ce moment-là
deuxième phase on est dans un combat
d'infanterie pur et dur c'est les
tranchées c'est tous les combats qui ont
eu lieu dans l'Est où il a pas pu
déboucher sur les emmerdes noires il est
resté sur des combats terrestres où là
il a il a pu apprécier entre guillemets
la montée en puissance la montée en
gamme de l'armée de l'armée ukrainienne
qui a été dotée de matériels les plus
performants de la même américaine
indéniablement où là il a senti quand
même le comment dire le le le souffle du
boulet parce que il peut pas contrôler
la technologie américaine si vous voulez
appliquer à son armée qui est d'une
armée extrêmement rustique rudimentaire
même s'il est assez massive si vous
voulez ça commence à changer et ça
modifier le rapport de force et on voit
et là il a parlé assez peu nucléaire en
fait la deuxième phase et troisième
phase il est dans le nucléaire et ça
c'est l'ultima ratio et le vrai problème
qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est que
il a il est doté on va dire de 6000 tête
nucléaires en fait on sait trop rien on
va dire auto les similaires donc c'est
un des principaux mondial premier point
puis le deuxième point la question est
premier point ce qui est de menace oui
est-ce qu'il peut l'utiliser je n'en
sais rien personne n'en sais rien et moi
quand tu as un Quentin quand un type
entre guillemets est à X milliers de
kilomètres et qui me dit qu'il a
largement nucléaire et qui joue avec les
boutons
ça m'interpelle donc on est obligé
il y a un petit travail de à faire en
disant qu'est-ce qu'on fait et ça on
peut pas l'écarter d'emblée c'est tout
le problème qu'on est aujourd'hui alors
je réponds qu'on parle de de cette
terminologie là de qu'on entend depuis
plusieurs semaines les armes nucléaires
tactiques et je vais faire référence à
Hiroshima et Nagasaki il y a eu au moins
340000 morts d'abord lors des
expériences puis ça c'est le bilan à 5
ans avec mais en fait on aura sans doute
jamais un bilan précis de de ce que
représente ces deux bombes nucléaires et
de seul évidemment de l'histoire
arme nucléaire tactique est-ce que c'est
la même puissance c'est pas lequel
d'entre vous va répondre parce que
peut-être qu'ils sont des hommes à
courte portée ce sont des armes de
combat les armes de bataille pour gagner
la guerre pas pour l'empêcher les armes
stratégiques sont normalement faites
pour empêcher la guerre puisque après
rechute Nagasaki on a conceptualisé la
dissuasion mais là c'était une puissance
une arme nucléaire
donc elle peut d'ailleurs avoir une
puissance comparable à Hiroshima mais ce
qui c'est la portée donc on est là c'est
pas une arme qui peut atteindre le
territoire des pays européens ce serait
une arme qui serait lancé le changement
de bataille la France avait ce type
d'armes il y a renoncé en disant que
c'était contraire à sa doctrine puisque
pour les Français il faut
la langue n'est pas là pour gagner la
guerre mais pour l'empêcher on avait des
armes nucatiques ce qui pose un peu les
vrais que les Allemands disaient c'est
bien joli vous dites que vous allez vous
protéger avec ses armes elles vont
tomber chez nous donc ça nous protège
pas beaucoup mais en fait tactique ou
stratégique le nucléaire c'est le
nucléaire et si la Russie utilisait une
arme nucléaire fut-elle tactique de plus
faible puissance quoique quand même ça
ferait des dizaines de milliers
c'est que le tabou absolu que à travers
toutes les crises qui de la guerre
froide à la fin de la guerre froide ce
sont succédés l'arme nucléaire a été
brandi plusieurs fois rappelez-vous Cuba
rappelez-vous la guerre de Corée 73 il y
a eu de multiples exemples où on a un
peu un peu enfin Cuba étant l'exemple
plus typique mais jamais jamais ce tabou
nucléaire n'a été brisé depuis 1945 et
donc là la Russie qui est déjà hors la
loi se mettrait hors société
internationale si elle utilisait l'arme
nucléaire puisque vous voulez une
échelle de valeur parce que c'est
toujours intéressant d'abord le tactique
on l'a plus on en parle plus de en
France on en a pas on en a plus depuis
Jacques Chirac le deuxième point c'est
que c'est une on l'a pu donc pour tout
essayer de raisons la deuxième point
c'est une arme de non-emploi pas du
nucléaire comme une arme c'est absurde
mais ça n'a aucun sens depuis 45 on a
décidé que c'était une arme de
non-emploi une arme de dissuasion et
troisième point pour entrer dans votre
échelle de valeur simple un sous-marin
nucléaire
un sous-marin nucléaire lanceur d'engin
gros sous-marin français qu'on a on en a
quatre il y a quatre silos à l'intérieur
chaque silo c'est un missile donc vous
avez 16 missiles et chaque missile au
règlement il est myrv c'est en fait il y
a 10 tête à l'intérieur et chaque tête
Hiroshima en fait le total 16 x 10 x
Hiroshima donc vous avez pas après le
total de la puissance d'un seul
sous-maries c'est passionnant ce que
vous nous dites l'un et l'autre parce
que effectivement Christine Clément
c'est une arme de non-emploi sauf que là
dans la rhétorique je reviens la
rhétorique on a l'impression depuis
quelques semaines que ben on imagine ou
on aimait l'hypothèse de son emploi lors
de ce conflit en Ukraine c'est en fait
c'est là-dessus que la Russie joue
beaucoup c'est sur l'ambiguïté de
l'usage c'est à dire que nous
effectivement c'est une arme de
non-emploi que on utiliserait que déjà
que en riposte et que en ultime recours
dans le cas où les intérêts vitaux de la
nation qui restent en règle générale
volontairement flou comme on le disait
l'ambiguïté fait partie de l'enjeu et
qui ne serait utilisé que à ce moment-là
sauf que on peut imaginer qu'on aurait
une utilisation du nucléaire dans un
esprit de l'ultime avertissement c'est à
dire de dissuasion de frappes dissuasive
où là on serait plus sur la même type
d'emploi et ça pose aussi la deuxième
question c'est à dire la capacité de
d'usage qui ne soit pas une réaction ou
une réaction à une attaque militaire
mais potentiellement à une perception et
c'est là où justement et c'est encore
une fois c'est tout l'intérêt des
doctrines de dissuasion c'est de pouvoir
jouer sur cette espèce d'éléments de
flux et d'ambiguïté donc quand à l'usage
quant à la nature de ce que vous allez
de ce que vous allez pouvoir en faire
alors justement ça vous m'offrez la
transition pour écouter un extrait de la
déclaration du président République
c'était la semaine dernière sur France 2
il a rappelé qu'elles étaient les
principes de notre doctrine nucléaire en
l'écoute
la France a une doctrine nucléaire je le
disais et notre doctrine repose sur ce
qu'on appelle les intérêts fondamentaux
de la nation et ils sont définis de
manière très claire et donc ce n'est pas
du tout ça qui serait en cause il y
avait
par exemple une attaque balistique
nucléaire en Ukraine ou dans la région
par contre ça n'appellerait pas une
réponse nucléaire
conventionnel évident c'est ça n'est pas
notre doctrine aujourd'hui je le dis
nous avons un cadre pour ce qui nous
concerne
Mathieu cette réponse à la surprise plus
d'un titre à la fois les Français et les
experts d'abord parce qu'il est très
rare qu'un chef de l'État est donc chef
des armées s'exprime sur ce sujet la
dernière fois qu'il avait parlé de la
doctrine nucléaire c'était ça monte à
deux ans lors d'un discours prononcé
dans les stagiaires de l'école de guerre
et comme le disait Christine Dubois
Clément en la matière en matière de
dissuasion d'un certain flou une
certaine ambiguïté sont quasiment aussi
importantes que que l'arme elle-même la
deuxième chose qui a surpris c'est la
notion d'intérêt fondamentaux qu'on a
entendu dans l'extrait qui avancé par le
chef de l'État parce que
traditionnellement dans la nucléaire on
parle plutôt de l'intérêt vitaux alors
on s'est interrogé quels sont-ils toute
façon ces intervie vitaux et ben ils
sont précisés nulle part il appartient
au président donc décidé ça fait partie
de ce flou et de cette ambiguïté alors
que la notion d'intérêt fondamentaux de
la Nation pour le coup il existe elle
est beaucoup plus précise elle est même
définie par l'article 410 relatives au
crime et délit contre la nation l'État
et la paix publique mon code pénal et ça
dit quoi les intérêts fondamentaux de la
nation c'est l'indépendance l'intégrité
du territoire la sécurité la forme
républicaine de institutions les moyens
de défense et de sa diplomatie la
sauvegarde la population à l'étranger et
en France de l'équipe de son milieu
naturel de son environnement essentiel
de son potentiel scientifique et
économique et même de son patrimoine
culturel donc là c'est ici c'est ça qui
devient la doctrine de dissuasion
française si vous voyez que ça existe
est beaucoup plus précise et qu'on est
plus dans le flou et dans cette ambigu
d'un seul coup c'est c'est très détaillé
ce qui a surpris aussi c'est le fond de
la réponse d'Emmanuel Macron sur donc
cette riposte en cas de tir nucléaire
sur le territoire ukrainien oui parce
que là encore il est pas dans l'usage
dans la dissuasion nucléaire d'abattre
son jeu avant même de connaître les
cartes que compte jouer son adversaire
dire nous le risque pour nous ne
riposterons pas d'emblée alors ça
rassure peut-être les Français mais ça
peut aussi raisonner comme un laissé
faire pour une autre partie de l'opinion
par ailleurs lors du discours devant
l'école de guerre auquel je faisais
allusion tout à l'heure le président a
une petite phrase qui n'avait pas
échappé aux spécialistes c'était soyons
clairs les intérêts vitaux de la France
ont désormais une dimension européenne
dès lors on peut se demander est-ce
qu'une frappe nucléaire nucléaire pardon
Ukraine revêtirait ou non une dimension
européenne beaucoup d'experts expliquent
que aujourd'hui l'Ukraine est en immense
de l'Union européenne ni de l'OTAN il y
a pas de changement de doctrine tout au
plus peut-être une maladresse ou un mot
pour un autre employé par le chef de
l'État les lisait en tout cas on se
refuse à commenter ou à préciser les
propos du président en la matière c'est
le retour à une forme de d'ambiguïté on
sort on le sait ce détriment des
ambiguïté
est-ce que le président est resté dans
les clous de la doctrine nucléaire
française d'après vous avec cette
déclaration
c'est une très bonne question on peut se
la poser moi je pense qu'il a essayé de
clarifier les choses pour essayer de
rassurer la population française
simplement parce que le truc du
nucléaire c'est c'est un vrai sujet donc
je pense qu'il y a une vraie inquiétude
il voulait jouer son rôle de père de la
nation et de dire que c'était en fait
assez simple il a voulu clarifier la
situation en fait c'est presque aucune
réponse politique que militaire je pense
qu'il a pas voulu c'est comme ça je vois
les choses il a rassuré et je pense dans
les mots qu'il est utilisé fondamentaux
il a voulu dire rue Vito honnêtement je
je pense vraiment il a pas pensé
fondamentaux oui un truc comme ça
il a pas pensé que ça voulait dire que
encore que on peut se poser la question
mais je pense qu'il était un petit peu
rapide sur le sujet le problème de fond
c'est que l'addition nucléaire s'endogme
c'est pas seulement une doctrine c'est
un dogme c'est quelque chose qui était
construit qui a construit la paix en
Europe depuis 45 donc si espèce de ce
truc extra structuré qu'on peut pas
comme ça c'est pas le café du commerce
on peut pas en parler comme ça et je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui alors pas
seulement le chef de l'État mais une
espèce de discussion une espèce de
happning généralisée en France où tout
le monde a son avis sur le sur la
question bien évidemment et donc ça a
posé la question est-ce qu'on dit
participe finalement en organisant à
débat comme celui-là avant que c'est un
doc qui est immuable parce que le
problème c'est que ce dogme fonctionne
que lorsqu'il est justement il y a des
critères de suffisance etc mais surtout
par le secret par l'ambiguïté par le
fait que on va consulter l'angoisse
c'est l'ennemi potentiel si on raconte
tout tout de suite en permanence le
système ne fonctionne pas et le dogme
vendez là après la doctrine c'est de la
c'est de la vaisselle comme on dit c'est
les petits trucs mais le problème le
dogme on veut pas le changer et là on
sent que le dogme peut être altérer et
c'est intéressant parce que ça ça
rejoint ce que ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure sur la banalisation des des
propos ou des théories autour de l'usage
du nucléaire non là c'est la guerre donc
on reparle du nucléaire c'est normal que
en période de guerre on parle plus du
nucléaire qui est censé l'empêcher ou
qui est le dernier recours et dans la
mesure où il y a un débat qu'on est dans
une sorte de glissement pour l'instant
rhétorique mais qui pourrait finir par
de nombreux maintenant c'est que il faut
répondre aux inquiétudes du public à
partir du moment où pour nous inquiéter
en Russie certains agitent la menace
nucléaire il est normal que le public
s'inquiète enfin on a tous des retours
de nos voisins des gens que l'on connaît
et qui se disent voilà qui ce qui va se
passer etc c'est le rôle du président de
calmer le jeu et de ratio la nation par
contre ce qui n'est pas son rôle c'est
de dire à l'avance qui ne va faire ou
pas faire puisque la dissuasion c'est
justement ne pas dire à l'avance ce que
l'on va faire une petite erreur de
répondre à la question sur en cas de
l'Ukraine à la fois il ne fait que
rappeler une évidence l'Ukraine ne fait
pas partie des intérêts vitaux de la
France on va pas utiliser l'arme
nucléaire pour des pays qui ne sont pas
membres de l'Union européenne il y a
même pas de certitudes qu'on le fasse
pour des pays membres de l'Union
européenne pour la c le territoire
national le sanctuaire et les interviews
les vidéos ça s'appelle l'Allemagne ça
peut être la Belgique ça peut être des
alliés pas l'Ukraine mais il faut pas le
dire de même que Biden a tellement
répété que quoi qu'il se passe il y aura
pas la guerre que ça peut être ressenti
comme une sorte de feu vert par Poutine
donc en fait il faut jamais dire à
l'avance que l'on fait parce que la
dissuasion c'est que l'autre en face
s'interroge et ne sache pas ce que vous
allez faire c'est pas que vous vous
soyez sûr de pouvoir l'atteindre c'est
que lui puisse avoir peur que vous
puissiez l'atteindre et donc aux menaces
virtuelles venant des Russes il aurait
mieux fallu répondre par un silence
est-ce que Christine c'est pas une forme
de de fragilité pour l'Ukraine qui a
demandé une adhésion accélérée à l'OTAN
mais qui mais qui n'y est pas encore il
faut peut-être rappeler ce qui est le
principe de la défense collective de de
l'OTAN est-ce que ça fonctionnerait en
cas de frappe nucléaire d'ailleurs alors
encore une fois il y a plusieurs choses
c'est à dire que
et on l'a tous dit ici le nucléaire
répond à des doctrines de l'État qui
tient ce qui est dépositaire de cette
puissance nucléaire donc il est le seul
à pouvoir et c'est pour ça qu'on parle
des intérêts vitaux avec plus ou moins
de flou plus ou moins d'ambiguïté
nécessaire de la nation en question donc
c'est là où quand on se dit bah voilà
quels sont les intérêts vitaux est-ce
qu'on pourrait les étendre à des pays
alliés s'il y a des dépendances ou pas
reste là encore une fois la décision
présidentielle et de ce que l'on en
ferait et il est heureux que cela ne
soit pas transparent encore une fois on
a bien compris mais alors sur la
question de l'appartenance comment à
l'OTAN et l'utilisation de l'arme
nucléaire au cas où et bien sur la
question de l'appartement ou non on a
avant déjà de de dégainer le nucléaire
si je peux me permettre il y aurait déjà
la simple question de rentrer ou ne pas
rentrer dans le conflit au niveau de
l'OTAN par rapport à l'Ukraine et là on
a été quelque chose qui est il y a eu
plusieurs déclarations qui ont été
extrêmement clairs et les faits le
montre aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire que non
puisque si on avait voulu le faire en
disant que l'OTAN rentrait dans la
guerre suite à l'invasion massive de
l'Ukraine par la Russie c'est une guerre
même si la Russie appelle encore ça une
opération spéciale avec tout ce que l'on
veut c'est une vraie guerre donc on y
serait déjà allé donc si on n'est pas
parti sur du d'une guerre cinétique
classique traditionnelle c'est parfois
déjà une guerre cinétique et ben une
guerre militaire traditionnelle si vous
voulez ou vous allez avoir et bien de
l'armement lourd vous allez avoir des
hommes qui s'affrontent sans forcément
aller dessus concrètement on a compris
l'idée si jamais Poutine d'utiliser une
arme même tactique nucléaire il y aurait
pas de riz post nucléaire mais qu'est-ce
qu'elle pourrait être la riposte du coup
c'est en anglais du conventionnel a
répondu mais dit qu'il allait ratiboiser
les trois quarts de la marine la marine
russe en mer Noire ou de des unités
entières parce qu'en fait avec des
moyens conventionnels c'est aussi
destructeur que les moyens nucléaires le
nucléaire c'est une arme politique donc
c'est une espèce de de de de tabou vous
pouvez intouchables par contre utiliser
de l'armement conventionnel et
destructeurs ici autant destructeur qui
normalement nucléaires sans aucun
problème que les amis rentreraient en
guerre
et donc ça ferait une différence parce
que là c'est l'escalade qu'on ne
contrôle plus puisque du point de vue
russe le nucléaire les protège d'une
attaque conventionnelle pourquoi les
pays de l'OTAN qui sont plus armés que
la Russie qui sont plus puissants
militairement que la Russie n'attaque
pas la Russie c'est parce qu'elle a
l'arme nucléaire si la Russie n'avait
pas l'arme nucléaire on l'attaquerait
pas s'il a Yougoslavie a eu l'arme
nucléaire en 99 j'irai jamais eu la
guerre du Kosovo et donc s'il y avait
une attaque massive conventionnelle même
que conventionnelle sur la Russie la
doctrine nucléaire russe comme la
doctrine de tous les pays qu'on l'arme
nucléaire c'est dire vous ne pouvez pas
m'attaquer avec des armes
conventionnelles parce que sinon je vous
menace de vous raser d'utiliser l'arme
nucléaire donc là on rentre dans une
escalade qui peut aller aux extrêmes et
qui peut devenir incontrôlable
que vous venez de lever quand on regarde
donc la dernière les derniers textes qui
ont été signés par le président Poutine
justement quant à l'usage des forces
nucléaires donc en 2020 c'est assez
récent et bien il parle même notamment
d'une information fiable quant au
lancement de missiles balistique qui
serait sur le territoire russe donc on
est dans cette approche là de dire voilà
vous m'attaquez avec des armes
conventionnelles mais de manière massive
surmontée aux intérêts de la nation et à
la sauvegarde père de Jong en France
c'est le président seul qui décide
comment ça se passe
éventuellement un peu sur le bouton mais
en fait globalement il est aidé par un
environnement assez sérieux on va dire
des majeur des armées qui qui assure
mais la décision c'est lui alors ça
c'est bon le c'est le dogme intouchable
c'est lui qui va décider là encore une
fois aider par l'environnement par ses
collaborateurs etc il y a une décision
il y a c'est j'imagine que c'est
collégiale à minima et puis derrière et
la mise en œuvre là qui est qui roule et
qui rend tout seul c'est vrai que le
chef de l'État c'est lui qui décide et
puis sur le bouton alors évidemment vous
allez pas m'en dire beaucoup mais il y
en a plusieurs qui ont les codes en même
temps je veux pas de pas vous poser une
question curieux
honnêtement je vais je vais vous
répondre d'abord un le plus grand secret
de la République c'est donner qui
existent donc je vais pas le trahir
aujourd'hui ce serait dommage que là je
me ferai couper en rondelle en sortant
de votre studio donc ça je vais pas le
faire le deuxième truc c'est beaucoup
plus simple les créateurs de ça on crée
un système dans lequel le chef de l'État
peut toujours décider du feu nucléaire
quel qu'il soit l'aide de quand il ne
sert qu'à un seul moment quand il est à
l'étranger pendant l'étranger les
conditions de communication du chef de
l'État avec sur l'état-major de cette
performante alors c'est des satellites
etc l'environnement de transmission de
de trucs cryptique etc ça c'est le rôle
de l'aide de camp c'est de créer un
environnement autour du chef de l'état
où il peut discuter parce qu'il va pas
le faire tout seul au fin fond de moi en
fait j'étais en Côte d'Ivoire avec avec
Jacques Chirac il me dit et à mon
colonel si on fait le nucléaire
maintenant
ce prénom on a besoin de 5 minutes quoi
juste pour régler le problème quoi donc
ça va pas se régler comme ça bien
évidemment donc le vrai problème c'est
qu'il faut créer les conditions une fois
que les ces conditions là il va il va
discuter à ce moment-là il y a un
problème de code le rôle de Caen n'est
que de que de vérifier que le chef de
l'État et le chef de l'État est en état
c'est que si le s'il a une un pétard sur
la tête et moi aussi par la même
occasion parce que comme je suis pas
bien loin ben ça fonctionnera pas donc
il y a un système qui était prévu et un
système fabuleux et qui n'est pas
technique ce que je vais vous expliquer
c'est qu'il y a pas de technique le but
c'est que c'est un système totalement
humain qui est tellement simple que je
l'ai oublié alors je vous parle c'est
paradoxal si vous voulez le cerveau à
nettoyer ses auto nettoyer et j'ai
totalement oublié je me rappelle du
processus mais j'ai tout oublié c'est
absolument incroyable et en fait c'était
extrêmement simple qui fait que le le
camp ne fait que vérifier si vous voulez
l'état dans lequel le chef de l'État a
décidé maintenant s'il avait des pieds
sur tous les boutons de la terre les
deux camps ne peut pas interférer ces
décisions totalement politiques et qui
va prendre en termes collégial discute
avec son chien était majeur des armées
etc après il y a tout un système de
protection et de comment dire de
sécurisation de l'information et qui
valait jusque sous-marin nucléaire et
dans le sous-marin vous avez le
commandant plus le second qui ont le
même système ils effectuent le même
geste pour tirer des missiles j'ai juste
une question qui peut s'appliquer au cas
de la France mais aussi au cas de Moscou
un président fou peut-il appuyer décider
tout seul d'appuyer sur le bouton
c'est qu'il soit structuré suffisamment
pour qu'il puisse pas l'ordre vous savez
dans nos lois un officier d'exécute un
ordre que lorsqu'il est légal et donc si
on considère qu'il est légal on exécute
pas c'est un vrai sujet c'est vrai que
le choix d'un être de Caen est un choix
je dirais quasiment mystique quand on
disait tout à l'heure Poutine pourra pas
prendre la décision tout seul d'utiliser
l'arme nucléaire chaque pays a son
système si vous voulez en France les
deux camps il a une fonction parce que
le voyage le président voyage beaucoup
et une fonction d'accompagnement après
quand il est en France il a le PC
Jupiter il descend il y a plein de gens
il y a plein il est aidé les deux camps
n'a pas de fonction là le rôle de cons
c'est de vérifier que le chef de l'État
est en fonction et puis que le Président
vous dise bon je suis bien vous êtes
bien on va appuyer ensemble sur le
bouton mais on va faire un truc en
collégiale mais c'est vrai que le rôle
de camp c'est quand même d'empêcher
surtout une menace extérieure c'est
possible vous êtes chez lui il se passe
des choses
j'étais au Mondial de l'Auto lundi quand
le président de la République la visite
je crois enfin World je me trompais mais
il y avait son aide de camp avec la
sacoche alors c'est quoi le cas de
figure c'est il y aurait une attaque
peut-être terroriste il serait bloqué à
l'intérieur il faudrait qu'ils puissent
prendre une décision que l'endroit où il
est il y a un bureau qui a été
prédéterminé dans lequel vous allez
transmetteurs qui sont installés dans
quelle hypoton téléphoner avec des
moyens cryptés
mais par contre les deux camps à la
limite là c'est de dimensions présents
suivez-moi on va dans la salle et la
salle est un est à 40 mètres on y va et
là il peut communiquer dans un
environnement qui qui éclaire vous savez
le mythe de la sacoche j'ai pas le
casser aujourd'hui parce que c'est quand
même une formidable donc mais à part un
sandwich une bouteille d'eau et puis le
quartier de section comme on dit il y
avait pas grand chose dedans
est-ce qu'on peut parce qu'elle Boniface
répondre à la question que Mathieu posé
sur la Russie
le président enfin le Poutine mais aussi
son Shelda majeur et le mise des armées
donc il serait trois à prendre par le
décisionnaire final bien sûr le
président en France comme aux États-Unis
comme en Russie mais il y a une sorte de
V pas de veto mais de contrôle que
l'ordre est bien donné par quelqu'un qui
a tous ces moyens et je pense que dans
le cas alors bon bien sûr quand rien qui
pète les plombs ou qui est désespéré par
la banque le suicide dans le bunker etc
là les gens les autres diront écoute tu
peux te suicider mais tu suffisait pas
la Russie et donc tu décides tout seul
on va maintenant parler des autres pays
qui ont l'arme nucléaire sont fausses à
Mathias de nous rejoindre rebonsoir
Mathias alors vous allez répondre à la
question qui qui possède l'arme
nucléaire aujourd'hui dans le monde et
bah ils sont peu nombreux aujourd'hui à
pouvoir se prêter au jeu de la
dissuasion car l'arme ne circule pas
beaucoup aujourd'hui il y a trois
catégories de pays qui est long 1 les
états l'ayant et signataires du traité
de non prolifération des armes
nucléaires donc les États-Unis la Russie
le Royaume-Uni la France et la Chine de
les ayant reconnu la possédée donc
l'Inde le Pakistan et la Corée du Nord
puis enfin le seul État ne reconnaissant
pas officiellement la détenir Israël et
alors qu'est-ce qu'on sait du nombre de
missiles l'état des stocks d'armes
nucléaires et bien c'est très disparate
sans rentrer dans le détail des
différents moyens de lancement on trouve
loin devant la Russie avec environ 6000
armes les États-Unis sont juste derrière
avec 5500 tête nucléaires en 3e position
on retrouve la Chine et ces 350 armes et
puis la France et ces quelques 290 tête
nucléaires au total tout pays confondu
il y a près de 13000 tête nucléaires
opérationnels dans le monde alors un
chiffre toutefois à relativiser puisque
depuis la fin de la guerre froide les
programmes de désarmement se multiplient
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée au
milieu des années 80 il y avait plus de
70 000 armes nucléaires dont 40 000 au
seul main des Soviétiques et parmi les
programmes de désarmement il y a
également ce traité d'interdiction
complète des essais nucléaires et oui
article
qui est un parti s'engage à ne pas
effectuer d'explosion expérimentale
d'armes nucléaire alors ce traité signé
en 1996 prévoit donc l'arrêt de tout
type d'essai nucléaires avec l'ambition
d'avancer vers le désarmement
aujourd'hui 194 États ont signé pour
seulement 168 qui l'ont ratifié alors
parmi les puissances nucléaires ne
l'ayant pas ratifiant on retrouve la
Chine et les États-Unis ne l'ayant tout
simplement pas signé l'Inde le Pakistan
et la Corée du Nord à noter que seul la
Corée du Nord a procédé à des essais de
ce type au 21e siècle merci Mathias
6000 armes pour la Russie 5500 pour les
États-Unis est-ce qu'on Christine
éventuellement est-ce qu'on en est sûr
puisque on a on a passé beaucoup de
temps à dire c'est l'ambiguïté qui qui
domine il faut pas trop en dire sur sa
sur sa puissance est-ce que est-ce que
ces chiffres sont sont vérifiables d'une
certaine façon alors en fait quand on va
parler de nucléaire
pour pouvoir avoir un système de
dissuasion ça suppose que vous soyez en
capacité merci d'avoir une maintenance
technologique de l'armement
quel que soit les conditions en fait le
contexte que vous allez avoir quant à au
nombre de têtes et bien c'est toujours
un petit peu un enjeu on parlait par
exemple des États qui ont reconnu du
goût des lèvres avoir et de certains
dont on ne sait pas là évidemment on
peut avoir un flou qui va être qui va
être assez important ce qu'il y a une
particularité néanmoins de la Russie
c'est d'avoir finalement des armes
d'emports qui pourraient qu'ils puissent
à la fois porter de l'arme nucléaire et
de l'arme non nucléaire et ça ça
participe à justement cette ambiguïté
quant à la stratégie et quant à l'usage
c'est à dire que par exemple vous pouvez
avoir un calibre ou un Iskander qui
peuvent être chargés avec une frappe
traditionnelle ou avec une ou avec une
tête nucléaire
[Musique]
le nombre de têtes en fait il finit par
être assez relatif parce que c'est pas
très grave parce qu'il y a trois
problèmes le vrai problème c'est un défi
technologique que vous avez dit avec 16
voilà 16 missiles
par contre le vrai problème c'est le
défi technologique il y en a trois le
premier c'est la capacité de pénétration
de votre missile il faut qu'il soit sûr
qu'il puisse pénétrer dans le dispositif
adverse le deuxième c'est l'endroit
c'est la discrétion des sous-marins
nucléaires c'est à quel moment on peut
le tirer correctement pour pas être
repéré parce que l'acoustique si vous
voulez le sous-marin est repérable même
s'il est il est fait pour qu'il soit pas
repérable mais il y a et comment il peut
l'être donc il y a un endroit où il peut
tirer qui est un dernier secret parce
que pour le coup c'est pas la mallette
c'est un vrai secret de la République
c'est à quel moment on peut tirer le
sous-marin nucléaire actuellement il se
met pour pouvoir tirer deuxième point
puis troisième point c'est tout le
système anti-missile on voit bien que
les Russes ont déstabilisés le système
avec un système de missiles à haute
vélocité à grande vélocité et comment
arrêter un missile qui fait du 30000 km
à l'heure donc c'est extrêmement
difficile et donc le problème c'est la
pénétration des systèmes mais et donc
aujourd'hui il y a une vraie compétition
non pas en termes de nombre d'armes mais
en termes de capacité et technologique
celui de pénétrer si vous voulez et
c'est ça le problème c'est être sûr que
le missile arrive là où on l'attirait
c'est c'est ça l'enjeu aujourd'hui alors
allez-y juste d'où en fait l'intérêt des
démonstrations que l'on va avoir alors
on parlait des essais nucléaires mais
aussi des démonstrations sur des armes
supersoniques parce que on est justement
dans le prolongement de cette dissuasion
quand on est sur de larmes qui a une
capacité de charge dual parce que vous
démontrez que vous avez une arme qui va
être très difficile à intercepter donc
votre capacité de pénétration a augmenté
et vous rappelez
mezzovoché que vous pouvez la charger
avec ce que vous voulez ce qui permet un
petit peu de contourner la problématique
de l'interdiction des essais alors la
problématique quand on est dans une
approche de dissuasion entendons-nous
d'avoir ces essais qui soient
effectivement de la démonstration de
force et de la projection de puissance à
utiliser à utilité de dissuasion en tout
cas dernier petit exemple en termes de
chiffres on arrête je prends les Russes
avec le sarmat c'est comme une portée
globalement des 18000 fait à peu près
donc 9 et 10000 km donc si vous voulez
double portée de nous tu veux dire que
nous l'objet de tirer dans une direction
par contre eux ils peuvent faire le tour
de la terre donc ça c'est un vrai sujet
donc si vous êtes la capacité la haute
vélocité plus de la portée ça donne une
allonge incroyable donc aujourd'hui on
pourrait considérer je dis bien on
pourrait parce que j'ai pas été vérifié
que les que les Russes ont un véritable
avantage technologique et que s'ils
doivent tirer un missile nucléaire c'est
maintenant puisque aujourd'hui les
Américains et pour le moment nous on
travaille comme des brutes pour pour
atteindre ce niveau là et donc en fait
il y a une espèce de compétition en
termes de technologie et non pas en
termes de nombre d'armes et donc d'où
justement les annonces sur les supers
armes du président Poutine notamment en
2018 où alors on a utilisé aussi toute
une nomenclature qui est extrêmement
importante c'est à dire que votre côté
choque et froid vous le jouez aussi par
le par les mots et par le et par le nom
de l'armement et pour revenir donc sur
le Sarma tout ça en deux ce qui est
aussi intéressant c'est qu'en fait et
parfois c'est de la technologie assez
ancienne qui date des années 60 et qui a
été upgradée donc on a amélioré mais
finalement qui n'est pas aussi nouvelle
que ce que l'on amène aussi c'est à dire
que là aussi on a un jeu sur la
projection de puissance la capacité
technologique et la dissuasion qui est
intéressante en termes de capacité de
nouvelles production allez il nous reste
7 minutes à peu près dans ce débat
j'aurais quand même qu'on parle de la de
la Corée du Nord on l'a évoqué dans la
chronique de Mathias ares à l'instant
écoutez son président qui considère que
le statut d’état nucléaire de son pays
est irréversible
en inscrivant la politique de la force
nucléaire dans la loi le statut de notre
pays comme état doté de l'arme nucléaire
et devenu irréversible maintenant pour
changer notre politique nucléaire le
monde doit changer et le contexte
militaire et politique sur la péninsule
coréenne doit évoluer il est totalement
hors de question pour nous de renoncer à
l'harmonie nucléaire et il ne serait-il
avoir de dénucléarisation ou de
négociation
Pascal Boniface double question d'abord
est-ce qu'on est sûr que la Corée du
Nord a effectivement l'arme nucléaire et
puis ensuite pourquoi ça rejoint ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure en faisant
référence
au conflit dans les Balkans dans les
années 90 c'est une sorte d'assurance
pour dictateur l'arme nucléaire
ça peut paraître une provocation mais la
Corée du Nord à la même la même raison
d'avoir l'arme nucléaire que la France
c'est-à-dire ne pas être attaqué alors
c'est pas le même régime c'est pas les
mêmes raisons d'être attaquer et en fait
même lorsque Trump faisait des réunions
avec Kim Jongen personne n'a jamais cru
qu'on pourrait aller à d'une
éclairciation c'est son assurance vie
qui me jongle est très persuadé que si
Kadhafi et Saddam Hussein a eu l'arme
nucléaire sera encore en vie et au
pouvoir on va pas dire que le modèle du
régime nord-coréen soit un succès ça
rien ne marche l'économie et l'arme du
cœur n'est pas fait pour faire la guerre
à la Corée du Sud pas pour faire la
guerre au Japon il faut que la Corée du
sud du Japon est peur que la Corée du
Nord leur fasse pour ne pas être tenté
de vouloir démocratiser de force la
Corée du Nord et de ne pas faire
finalement le régime nord-coré il était
aussi horrible que Suisse à la musseine
en 2003 mais on a dit ça la Musset dans
le nucléaire il faut y aller il n'avait
pas le nucléaire c'est pour ça qu'il y a
eu la guerre et par contre la Corée du
Nord Eve et l'arme nucléaire ils
insultaient tous les jours les
Américains et les Américains ont dit bon
on va peut-être pouvoir un peu une
solution diplomatique avec la Corée du
Nord donc la Corée du Nord ne
dénucléisera jamais parce que c'est la
seule condition du survie du régime et
ce régime est tout à fait rationnel ils
ont réussi quand même un exploit à créer
un communiste héréditaire depuis trois
générations ce qui est quand même de
leur point de vue une réussite pas du
point de vue de la population mais du
point de vue réussite et l'arme
nucléaire c'est leur assurance vie
absolue parce que personne aux
États-Unis n'ira dire ah tiens il y a
une dictature ça serait bien d'aller
démocratiser cette dictature comme ils
l'ont fait dans d'autres pays colonel De
Jong je repose la que vous y avez en
partie répondu mais sur qu'est-ce qu'on
sait de d'armes nucléaires nord-coréenne
de sa fiabilité de parce que voilà c'est
un pays effectivement dans l'économie et
est très affaibli bon
est-ce qu'on a des réponses à cette
question il faut demander aux Japonais
parce qu'en fait on voit bien que les
Nord-Coréens ils tirent missile par
semaine quasiment un petit peu moins
enfin autour de autour du Japon en
permanence il teste et donc aujourd'hui
on a tout les chiffres balistiques de
porter de puissance etc il faut encore
ce qu'il faut pas c'est avoir la
certitude qu'il puisse atteindre le
Japon c'est craindre qu'il puisse le
faire et à partir du moment où il y a un
doute ceci donc je pense qu'ils ont les
moyens mais à partir du moment où il y a
un doute et bien l'effet dissuasif
existe parce que c'est intéressant c'est
que la Corée Corée du Nord a une
politique régionale donc en fait on voit
bien que les menaces elles sont pas
directement sur les Américains le but
c'est le Japon c'est c'est la 7e flotte
c'est Taïwan etc on est sur leur modèle
régional et ça c'est la force d'une
puissance régionale c'est d'avoir une
stratégie régionale deuxième point c'est
que le nucléaire ne disait que le
nucléaire c'est qu'en fait la dissuasion
ça fonctionne puisque en Europe ça a
fonctionné donc il applique un que nous
on applique depuis 1945 qui est que
Gilles nucléaire est donc Gérald De
Gaulle n'a pas réfléchi différemment il
est rentré dans la course des grands
avec le nucléaire on dit à partir de
maintenant la seule différence c'est que
nous on n'a pas tiré les missiles à
gauche et à droite de l'Allemagne de
toutes les 30 secondes ce que fait
aujourd'hui la Corée du Nord intervalle
régulier mais alors est-ce que est-ce
que c'est une une charge de risque plus
importante écoutez ce qu'on dit le
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la de la défense et des
forces armées au Sénat Christian Campbon
la course aux armes nucléaires elle
continue on le voit bien avec l'Iran on
le voit bien avec un certain nombre
d'autres pays et il faut être assez
vigilant pour faire en sorte que le club
des des puissances nucléaires ne
s'élargissent pas parce que tant qu'il
reste aujourd'hui il y a évidemment il y
a évidemment un risque et bien
évidemment il faut le surveiller parce
que si l'arme nucléaire est dans la main
de de
pays voyou là les de graves drames
risque de nous toucher bien évidemment
Christine ou un Clément est-ce que c'est
le fait que la Corée du Nord possède
l'arme nucléaire ou que souvent on
cherche à la posséder est-ce que ça
change l'analyse du risque nucléaire ou
pas d'ailleurs alors en fait ce qu'il
faut voir et c'est ce que l'on disait
c'est que pour beaucoup de pays c'est
d'arriver à avoir une assurance vie et
une capacité de se défendre eux-mêmes
certains se rappelleront que l'Ukraine
avait des nucléarisé contre une
assurance 1994
[Musique]
et que certains montrent du doigt que
peut-être tout n'a pas été respecté
qu'un seul aurait dû être ce que l'on
voit c'est qu'on a une augmentation de
manière générale des conflictualités des
tensions et que alors on parle souvent
d'un d'une nécessité d'un contexte de
confiance pour arriver à un désarmement
serait-il partielle bon là le contexte
de confiance au niveau mondial pense
qu'on peut dire qu'il est quand même
assez mal en point
en enfonçant un petit peu une porte
ouverte et en faisant la palissade du
soir ce qui fait que évidemment vous
aurez des appétences pour des pays
d'avoir des systèmes d'armes qui
puissent leur proposer et les prémunir
de ce type d'attaque ce qui peut être
aussi intéressant et c'est là où la
Russie en terme de de dialectique est
intéressante quand elle nous explique
que peut-être elle pourrait utiliser
donc de la frame tactique donc un petit
peu de premier appel et qui aurait une
visée de désescalade dans un conflit
dans l'air géographique proche bah là ça
repose la question pour d'autres
puissances nucléaires si jamais cette
frontière là était posée j'ai terminé
nous reste une minute parce qu'elle
Boniface avec vous et une question
peut-être un peu provocatrice est-ce que
le monde serait forcément plus sûr sans
arme nucléaire
c'est alors pour les pays qui l'ont
c'est la certitude de ne pas être en
guerre mais ils veulent pas que d'autres
prix Lay donc c'est le paradoxe
nucléaire n'est utile que pour ceux qui
l'ont merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à elle était lourde la
sacoche la valise il y avait des
bouteilles ça dépend du poids de la
bouteille d'eau c'est ça merci beaucoup
à tous d'avoir participé à ce débat
Pascal Boniface j'appelle le titre de
votre de cette bande dessinée avec le
dessinateur Tommy géostratégique la
géopolitique mondiale de 1945 à nos
jours c'est aux éditions du nom
graphique voilà merci à toutes et à tous
de votre fidélité je vous donne
rendez-vous demain 18h et 22h les deux
diffusions de sens public et puis
l'invité de la matinale c'est Patrick
kaner le président du groupe socialiste
au Sénat face à Oriane Mancini demain
matin 8h belle soirée
[Musique]